next class it's gonna be a more advanced
class so
i will talk about some interesting
opening
and also maybe show you one of my games
okay
so let's take a look at this opening
king's indian defense
v4 knight f6
c4 g6
at the moment we don't know the name of
the opening yet okay
it could be a grunfeld it could be a
king's indian
so we have to wait for one more move 93
now bishop g7 now we know this is the
king's indian defense
it's a very tough opening gary kasparov
played it for many many years
a very very tough opening so now
i continue with knight f3
castles
bishop g5 this is my favorite
uh setup against the king's indian and
i've been playing it for many many years
it's called smithslof petrossian okay
thank you thank you some king i
appreciate the compliment and glad
you've been
watching and enjoying my content so
and on youtube channel of course so now
he plays
this is the international master i'm
facing with the white pieces
so you play d6
e3 in this setup you play with the pawn
on e3
now i played c5
very aggressive move attacking the
center
i played d5
now he plays h6 attacking the bishop
bishop h4
g5 he's chasing my bishop
very aggressive and very concrete uh
play by my opponent chasing my bishop
now i go back here
bishop g3
knife is knight h5 when nitrogen when
they play h6 g5
it's extremely likely they were gonna
play knight h5 because that's the
the point they compromise a little bit
weaken the position but they're gonna
get your dark square bishop
i go bishop d3
developing my bishop
it does weaken his king i agree with you
and here
um black should play like something
like e6 here that's one of his best
options because
already i have some threats with knight
g5 okay
like if you play a6 let's say you don't
do anything i take
if you take you lose the knight and it's
made on h7
and so just bad
if you take
now we go check
queen h5
and knight e4 13 bishop g6 and queen h7
mate
yeah it's important to play 94 because
you you want to make sure
you prevent knight f6 knight doesn't get
here
defending because we go check
we go check and we go mate
if he goes here again check
animate
uh and yeah if you're wondering what
happens if you play
rook e8 let me ask you the question what
happens if he does that
how are we gonna mate him now we have to
play this precisely though
what's wrong with this move what kind of
strong follow-up i have here guys
yes queen f7 correct
taking the pawn and now we're just gonna
move the bishop
so whatever he does now we're just gonna
move the bishop
he interposes we made this way
or i can also mate with the
queen so blocking is completely busted
so let's go back to the game
um so
so basically i have a threat here
already when i play bishop d3 i'm
threatening to take on g5
now play e6
now yeah i mean he can play six or
uh the move he played in the game if e6
is probably the best move
against this i will probably have two
options here one is
to go knight d2
it takes and just take back this is one
option
play this position and the second option
is to play something like uh
bishop to c2
and queen d3
and queen d3 putting pressure on h7
so it takes
i normally play something like this so
it's a very sharp position here
um i would say it's it's unclear
white sometimes even plays g4 to
sacrifice a pawn to open up the diagonal
something like this
to have some ideas
this is what i was expecting but to my
surprise my opponent
played e5 here
okay and this came as a surprise because
i wasn't expecting this
but this is a blunder okay
this is a blunder by international
master kabanov
from russia how are we gonna take
advantage of this blunder here guys
well we need to have a follow-up right
we need to have a follow-up
so
so
do
knight takes e5
the issue is he takes
all right take back he takes her peace
okay
by andy 926 on paul son the french word
right
on poisson but what if he takes back
andy what's the follow-up now what if he
just takes back
what is the follow-up because it looks
like now
he's got some pretty active bishops
okay
he's got some pretty active bishops
bishop takes d6 fantastic
look at that move guys fantastic because
now if he takes back
if he takes back that's a problem right
if he takes back what do we do
if he takes back
check
takes
and takes back with a quinn
absolutely
picking up that quinn
i'm just picking that up
and if he goes here
rook e8 what do we do now
you
now if he doesn't take maybe take on c5
of course
why not why not extend that
to two pawn advantage okay
so when i played this move he he
suddenly realized that wait a minute
he realized that he can't just take back
this is a blunder
so he played here
knight takes g3 and now
what can i do here
now we play in between move
in between move taking on f7 with the
check
again you always have to remember guys
you always have to remember you're in
between moves okay
he takes you don't automatically assume
you gotta take back
look for those in between moves some in
between ideas if you can do something
instead okay now takes here
takes
it goes here
this
and now now i'm up a pawn
and now i would like to put some more
pressure so i go bishop g6
putting pressure on the rook
and now
he has to go here
now where do we bring the rook
oh here now opponent goes here bishop e6
now it's very important to try to trade
the light square bishops
now we go bishop to d5
now we're up a pawn well we could play
95 as well but it's better to trade the
bishops because
we're up upon he he doesn't have two
bishops anymore and we just got a lot of
a lot of pressure
we got a lot a lot of pressure okay
so
yeah now i cancel
and and basically the idea is just to
exchange
and get to a position like this where
you're up material okay
when you're up material you're never
afraid to trade okay
remember that when you're ahead you're
never afraid to trade so and i went on
to win the game
you know about 10 months later you know
just because the extra pawn
is just too much to handle but again it
shows again that even
strong players international masters if
they get into some
unfamiliar positions they can make a
mistake
and here we see a clear clear example
okay here we saw the clear example where
my opponent
just tried to do something like this
and uh
he tried to play a move like e5 and this
is not the
uh the only time i once played the
tournament
uh this was in australia uh 2008
and i was playing against 2300 players
in a this position in australia and
he decided that you know he can try to
just develop his pieces here
instead of playing e6 or something he
decided he can just play knight d7
but now this move loses as well okay
this move loses as well now why
why is this move losing
why is this move losing now
knight takes g5 correct if he takes back
we'll just go queen takes
putting pressure on h7 on g5 that's
perfect
now he takes
now we take and here my opponent
realized he can't take
and he played something like this and i
just came back and
i was up a pawn and went on to win the
game
quite comfortably but if he takes back
with this
this is very important here here we have
to play correctly here
because he wants to he wants to have a
defender he wants to bring this knight
on f6
as a defender okay
as a defender what can we do here
bishop h7 check
king h8 and now we go 94
to control this okay
now if he plays knight f6 now what do we
do
because he's preventing your queen from
coming in here
what do we do now
knight takes f6 if it takes
queen here and what if he tries to
escape here on g7
and try to go like rook h8 how we gonna
prevent that
how we're going to prevent that guys
because you know if you move the bishop
he goes rook h8
so moving the bishop it's not gonna do
it here
moving the bishop not quite gonna do it
for us
yep queen h6 of course to push him back
there
and then check very good
if he takes back with the pawn
we still go queen h5 again threatening
bishop check and mate what if he goes
rook e8
what is the problem now with that move
if he just plays rook e8 guys
queen takes f7 absolutely
queen takes f7 because now you want to
control the g8 square and now you're
ready to move the bishop
you move the bishop and mate
check animate
and it cannot go anywhere
okay yeah it's a light square
light squares domination okay we
dominate
on the light squares very important
animate all right very good guys
now we're gonna do some end game studies
okay i hope you enjoyed this king's
indian positions
and now we're gonna move on to some
difficult
end game studies
so this is a more advanced class so
you're gonna see more advanced
type of positions okay
white to play there are no pawns on the
board
so you have an extra piece here but it's
not easy to win this position okay
it's not easy at all to win this
position so the question is
what are we going to do here okay
what are we going to do here as white in
order to win this position
some very tricky a play needed some very
precise
play okay so let's see
white to play and win
you know again no puns on the board
which means if you trade queens it's
just a draw
so it's very very tricky
well you have to calculate we have to
calculate we can't just throw move
we have to calculate a little bit
because we have to have a good
plan because if you make one move it
doesn't work then
you can't really do the other one
so
so
so
so queen e7 looks like many people think
27 is our start okay
that is correct yes now if he goes back
to
h8 we have a mate okay
so if he goes here we have a mate
what if he goes here now king to g6
what if he goes to king to g6
do
now very special move needed very very
special move here
guys there are many checks but it's not
about just finding a check check check
you know it's not about just finding the
checks
it's all about finding a concrete plan
so
uh queen g5 yeah but
this he goes here 98 check king here i
don't see the follow-up guys
yeah we can do this but i don't see the
follow-up
so
so unfortunately um
this
a kg4 here threatens mate um
yeah this is a tricky move threatening
queen g7 made but the problem is
the queen ah queen before you take okay
yeah there is there is a very this is a
very tricky actually
there is a very strong defense he has
very strong defense he has here
so
queen g8 yes queen g8
only move guys only only move queen g8
and the problem is now if we check
he moves away and he checks us okay
and if we go here and now block can
force the draw here
do you see the spectacular way black can
force a draw here guys
how can he force a draw here
wow
queen g4 yes
takes and still made perfect
quincy vortex can't do anything
all right perfect
yep
so we go check so that's now that that
would be a spectacular way to end
the game nice work guys so
this is correct start so
it's not king g4 here so we know it's
not kg4 here
now what is the other follow-up we have
you know what is the other interesting
follow-up we have here
knight fa check okay
now if he goes here that's that's easy
right that's that's easy mate
or queen f6 mate or queen g5 mate
so he's gonna go here
king f5
this is a problem okay this is the
problem he will put the king on f5 and
now what do we do
do
um queen what
uh well he just played here it's white
to move
um queen g5 he will go to g5 e4
andy so
when g5 he escapes and then it might be
a draw
okay
sorry
queen h7 check okay
this is an interesting suggestion queen
e6 he just escapes queen is six
he you know he goes to f4 and f3 it's
unclear
now he goes here he can't go here the
one thing it's good that
we know he can't go here
because if he does that we have a fork
okay he can't go to f6
any five squares
so
okay because we have the fork
so now he goes here king f4
now a very important move needed here
yes
now this is the key moment we need a
very strong move here to win this game
setting up a mating net okay guys that's
what we're gonna do
we are going to set up the mating net
foreign
yep queen d3
correct now queen d3 is very strong move
guys
double exclamation mark because now
we have a very strong threat two threats
actually
but what is our first threat which is
the mate
what is our threat here guys
yeah did i think skewer
to win this and also threatening knight
g6 to mate
okay so that's a very important idea now
he can take but if he takes the knight
he's gonna run into another problem here
guys
what is the other problem
he's gonna run into
yep queen to f1 check
precisely precisely okay
he goes away thank you very much
picking this up
and that's made
yeah so that's the whole idea the queen
e7 is a natural move but then this
ideas are hard where you go check
here it's made
check
this is hard check and queen d3 it just
this is very very hard guys
okay all right excellent guys
this was difficult it's a very hard move
to find queen d3 this is
absolutely stunning move queen d3 here i
mean this this whole idea
but that's why this is a study this is
why i'm i'm showing you these positions
these are not a
positions you're just going to see every
day these are extraordinary positions
yeah all right
now we're gonna do one more guys one
more study okay for you
again there's not enough material here
it looks like
draw is a likely result okay
looks like draw might be the likely
likely result
how can we do it
white to play
white to play and win
let's not rush with ideas here guys
let's not rush let's try to
think a little bit and find the best
ideas let's not rush
okay because it's a very very tricky
position
i would spend couple of minutes before i
uh
go for some ideas
so
we have some uh potential pin right
we have some potential pin and that's
what we want to do we want to use that
potential pin here
but how
ugh
okay well it doesn't just win it may
look like it just wins but
bishop b2 is your best move
clearly that's your first move but it
doesn't just win
immediately
well we can't move run away so we have
to go here first
we have to go here first
now we go rook g3 check that's correct
so this way we're cutting him off now he
comes up
then what do we do guys
okay now he goes here then what we have
so
going g3 check
check so yeah
let's let's pause here this is a good
moment for us okay
this is a very good moment for us now
maybe we make a move to put him into a
suksawang okay
maybe we do something to put him in a
sukswang
block in sukshuang yes
king b1 now because if he gives us a
check
what do we have
coming back here perfect
blocking and taking the rook
okay
yeah so he here and after we play here
he doesn't have any good moves
anything he does is he's just going to
be in trouble and if he plays rook f6
if he plays rook f6 what do you do
we can't just take
look g1 and you take on f6
and we just take
perfect it's yeah just make sure you
don't take it okay don't don't get
excited and take it and then still make
the
opponent okay all right
and now yeah we're just trying to just
move and check if he goes here
now we have rook g3 check picking up the
rook
if he goes here then we check from c7
picking up the rook
so the last idea he can do is to play
rook f8 that's his last idea
but if he does this now what do we do
guys
again we gotta keep that king in the box
no rook h3 he has king g8 that will
allow him to escape yeah rook c7
cutting him off now has to go here
check and now
now we got him in the box again guys
what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do now
king a2 absolutely
absolutely king a2 and
he can't move the king anywhere do
anything he goes here
check
and we take this all right
so again always remember guys about
putting opponent
into a suksalang and now he cannot do
anything if he moves
further away anywhere like this you just
go check
and you take and once again if you place
this move
you don't take you just move it away and
then you capture in the next move
okay but don't play king b1 here because
if you play
king b1 here then he will have the
kamikaze rook okay
check and check it's a draw because you
can never take it's still made
so kamikaze rook okay so that's why you
play king a2
and now if he checks we have rook 87
attack all right so very important to
remember the idea of
putting opponent until 601k i recommend
you guys continue work on studies okay
studies will be very useful and will
help you
improve your game okay alright guys
so this will conclude this class